لقي ثمانيه اشخاص على الاقل مصرعهم في
ايطاليا واليونان كما سجلت خسائر ماديه
فادحه جراء حرائق الغابات التي ضربت دولا
اوروبيه كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى قدره الحكومات
الاوروبيه على التعامل مع تداعيات الكلفه
الفادحه لحرائق الغابات والى اي حد يمكن
ان تفاقم الخسائر المترتبه على هذه
الحرائق تركيز القاره على الامن الاقتصادي
كاولويه قصوى وما هي الاستراتيجيه التي
يمكن ان تلجا اليها اوروبا لمواجهه
تحدياتها الامنيه والمناخيه والجيوسيه
هذه الحرائق هي جزء من ازمه اخرى تنضم الى
الازمات الموجوده في اوروبا حاليا وهي
ممكن نسميها ازمه المناخ او ازمه التغير
المناخي والتي تؤدي الى ارتفاع تكاليف
الدوله للحفاظ على اولا انقاذ الارواح
انقاذ الاراضي ومن ثم معالجه هذه الاماكن
التي اصيبت بالحرائق كل ذلك يزيد الاعباء
على الحكومات على المصاريف الحكوميه التي
الان بشكل عام باوروبا يبدا تقليصها
السؤال ايضا الى اي حتى تستطيع الدول
الاستمرار
بمكافحه الحرائق يعني قد يكون هذا العام
جيدا ولكن ماذا عن الاعوام القادمه وهناك
جانب اخر اود ان اشير اليها ايضا هو
السياحه هناك صناعه ضخمه جدا خلف ذلك وهذا
سيتاثر بشكل كبير جدا لان ايضا علينا ان
نفكر بان كل تامينات السفر والتعويضات
يجب ان يعبدها احدهم اذا اضطر المسافرون
او السواح قطع اجازاتهم
مرتبطه بكفاءه الدول الاوروبيه لان الاداء
هو اداء غير متجانس يتعلق بالقوه
الاقتصاديه لاي دوله اوروبيه وكذلك مدى
جاهز يدها على اداره هذه الازمات القضيه
هنا تكمل في قضيه ان هذه ان هذه التحديات
هي مع التغييرات المناخيه يمكن ان تزداد
خطوره وبالتالي بعض الدول المتوسطه مثل
البرتغال وحتى ايطاليا ليست لديها قدره
كافيه ليس لديها مثلا اسطول كافي لبعض
الطائرات المخصصه لمكافحه الحرائق اوروبا
لم تتمكن من الوصول الى سياسه او
استراتيجيه موحده لعلاج الازمات الازمه
المناخ تاثيرها على البلديات تاثيرها على
الثروه الزراعيه الثروه الحواريه واقطع
السياحه سيكون كبير جدا الدول الاوروبيه
كاتحاد الاوروبي مجتمعه والدول السياديه
نفسها لم تعطي امكانيه ازمات بيئيه الوزن
الكافي للتحضير لها اولا ولمكافحها
مكافحتها ثانيا تراكميه هذه الاحداث تؤثر
على الاقتصاد الاوروبي وايضا علاء من
الجهه السياسيه الاوروبي
اكتشفت اوروبا بانها في النهايه هشه عندما
عندما اصبحت تستورد الكمامات من من الصين
عندما لم تستطع قادره كذلك على انتاج
اللقاحات الكافيه في ازمه الكوفيد من
الصعب جدا على اوروبا في النهايه ان تفتح
مسارات عده مسارات في الان واحد وتفتح
جبهات المتعدده في ان واحد قضيه الامن
الاقتصادي كذلك فك الارتباط مع الصين
اوروبا وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه مع اقتصاديا
لانها في النهايه كانت تعتمد عسكريا
وامنيا على الولايات المتحده يعني منذ
بدات الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
كانت احد المقولات ان ما قبل ربع والعشرين
من فبراير الشباط هو ليس ما بعده وفعلا
كان هذا يوم تغيرت فيه كل المعدلات
السياسيه السياسيه والاقتصاديه ومعادلات
الطاقه في اوروبا هناك
ركود قد ياتي قريبا
تحصل تغيرات يعني وايضا التحكم
بالتضخم الذي حصل في منطقه اليورو على
الرغم من استخدام اليات رفع الفوائد لم
تتم السيطره عليه بعد للاسف لا ارى اي
تفاؤل كبير لان الوضع ليس جيدا الان قد
تبدو مساله الحرائق مساله صغيره مساله
موجوده في مناطق معينه قد لا تؤدي الى
اضرار كبيره جدا الان ولكن التراكم
الازمات الصغيره في المناطق المختلفه
سيؤدي الى يعني كما نقول
تضادات اجتماعيه التي ستضغط على السياسه
من المؤكد ان تراكم هذه الازمات والعب
الذي في النهايه التي تسببه على
الميزانيات
الوطنيه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ستعيق من
طموح العديد من الدول الاوروبيه اذا كانت
هذه التراكمات الاجتماعيه
تسبب فعلا عدم استقرار داخل المنظومه
الحاكمه يعني داخل الحكومات الانذار
الاخير جاء من اسبانيا يعني راينا ان
اليمين المتطرف لم يصل الى ما يريده لكن
اصبح قوه سياسيه مهمه يمكن ان تصنع فعلا
من يحكم اسبانيا
ما زالت يعني متاحه بالنسبه للاتحاد
الاوروبي يعني يعني رغم كل الصعاب الاتحاد
الاوروبي ما زال واقفا يعني هناك تخصيص
لميداليات كبرى خاصه مثلا في ازمه كورونا
كما رايته الان كذلك في الحرائق لكن انا
اعتقد ان قوه الاتحاد الاوروبي من قوه
الدول التي ترفع التي تقود هذه الاتحاد
الاوروبي فانا اعتقد فعلا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يمكن ان ان ينهض من هذه الازمه
بشرط ان يكون هناك فعلا يعني توافق ما بين
الدول الاساسيه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي